as we continue to fight the pandemic
many are still dealing with health
issues and job loss
though we are slowly recovering many are
still dealing with depression or
addiction
after such a hard year since april is
alcohol awareness month bianca holman
shares the story of one former nfl
player
who overcame his alcoholic addiction
i would say addiction she is a beautiful
mistress but she will take it all from
you she's a very jealous lover patrick
vinsky is at desert hope addiction
treatment center
his affair with alcohol began in 2008
the housing market crash hit him hard
he went from being a multi-millionaire
realtor to living on food stamps in
order to support his family
i could tell i used alcohol just like a
tool like i used painkillers in the nfl
i struggle to function one more day
i didn't care about my long-term health
i just want to make it through one more
day so i can feed my kids
vinsky fights the misconception daily
about addiction being a
lack of self-control he was a gladiator
on the field for years
the first german citizen playing for
three nfl teams
the jaguars eagles and colts
binsky went from a casual drink enjoying
a nice glass of red wine with a steak
to something more oh you got the shakes
in the morning and you think maybe a
little white thought to watch the
sunrise would be great
and then by lunch you're like maybe 12
pack in you know
and you you don't feel like you're drunk
anything you just try to normalize
your feelings as vinsky finishes his
program at desert hope
he's five months sober and wants to
dedicate his life to helping others
i gotta call it big man or a van a big
man in a van and it's gonna be broadcast
and i wanna go through the united states
talking to high schools
sharing the message that it may start
and fun but sometimes addiction
may end in death bianca holman 8 news
now